wir haben wir Dennis Schneider am Tieren
der Deutscher Meister bei Starcraft 2
oder sag man in Deutschland ist richtig
kann man sagen okay wunderbar wie bist
du dazu gekommen
Z wie lang indem ich die EPS gewonnen
habe und wie güt hab sehr sehr viel also
vor dem Turnier sind das dann schon
seine 5 se Stunden am Tag und also nicht
nur reine Spielzeit sondern auch sehr
viel Gegner analysieren und die
Spielweisen Taktiken ja kommt viel kommt
viel bei zusammen nach Arbeit an ist
definitiv Arbeit okay und er kommt zu
klickum und natürlich heißt das ihr
könnt ihm wieder Fragen stellen am
besten als Video hochladen aber wir
nehmen ja inzwischen auch in den
Community Videos die Kommentare also
fleißig kommentieren und ich sag mal
welche Frage kriegst du immer gestellt
wie viel ich am Tag trainiere okay diese
Frage vielleicht nicht stellen also
kommt im Interview vielleichtan mal
sehen schauen wir mal also haut rein und
ich freue mich tierisch auf ihn
dennächst und ansonsten bis dann B dran
ciao ciao
ه